previously on TV since I pumped you and
your mute here out of the dirt blondie
saved your asses see safe no damn Jessie
a lot of folks went to a lot of trouble
to set up a super-secret Hospital for a
super secret kingpin and you're gonna
blow it by blowing up do you see the
obvious medical staff waiting for you at
a very specific location so why do you
have to park so goddamn far away are you
afraid you're Ron it's gonna get
scratched also why'd the medical staff
have to come out this far at all just
pull up to the goddamn door
look I know fluid sometimes comes out of
the syringe during prep but that's like
half the dosage ah tongues and needles
are not friends I mean just all the cues
show that feeling you get when that
weird question from a previous party if
Chris were Barrett was dying who would
you say becomes a reality this just made
me realize that the show and all the
opportunities it had never let Breaking
Benjamin so cold play over a scene that
feels like a sin just curious what the
next move is next three moves is sitting
here and waiting breaking The Walking
Dead
my brother-in-law shows up looking like
macho camacho and he thinks we're not
gonna discuss it macho camacho nice of
all the boxers to pull out of his but he
pulls Hector Comacho although I guess it
makes sense I heard his catchphrase was
I'm the one who knocks you out allergy -
oh wait don't say anything oh my see
what no problem how do you know that
jeez Jesse is it Walt but he's not an
idiot he has to know by now that Gus is
a thorough mother girl right feels like
this question could have played back at
season - maybe floor shadowing I'm not
judging you at Walt I'm just saying I
feel uncomfortable with it has there
ever been a character more annoying on
the show than mother Ted
I would take a 24-hour marathon
featuring to Gretchen's five Marines ten
gales and 20 Lydia's if I could get out
of one more second of intent I think
you're overstating things - no one's
going to prison
I bet when you think back on Breaking
Bad it's the Skyler tries to convince
Ted to pay his IRS debt storyline that
you love the most huh
I take your advice I pay the IRS then
one thing you don't owe them Schuyler
wouldn't be that bad at TV since that's
the Mercedes at least it before anywhere
the money came from hmm and now that you
know you will of course be returning it
well the lease is there pretty ironclad
so has time for conversations on
Mercedes leasing regulations make it
payable to the Internal Revenue Service
it will be long before it's tax time
again so a quick road tip from your
friends at TV since you actually pay the
Treasury not the IRS now that'll be a
hundred dollars for our tax advice
payable to TV sins at one five five
seven is this joke over yet Avenue
Nashville okay
what's the cattle Farmers of America
also every time he says Joaquin I think
at the Joker movie and that's a sin now
they said I'm on con named dice bring a
so great he's gonna be around to be
Walt's final nemesis on the show I'm
sure they wouldn't end that anytime soon
but I'll keep an eye out it's Jack and
boring as hell until it's not kind of
like this episode so you think all the
victims were cartel members Walt's
questioning has been so suspicious for
so long that Hank should officially have
all his law enforcement credentials
reversed by now what is the opposite of
a detective on oblivious to pink his
world class oblivious tip when you lose
your hair you got a couple stakeouts law
so you want your Kojak seen does not
contain a lollipop I said to mom ice
cream she was like it tastes the same
and tough year so sorry I I tried to say
just exactly the same show slows as it
goes to and fro to yo-yo it's pro or no
vote on Froyo yo and it feels like one
of those combs they put on dog so don't
lick their own balls
you mean lick where they used to have
balls you neutered canine insensitive
jerk Wow I'll tell you one thing your
Hardy Boys routine is over please Frank
and Joe would have had this thing
figured out and wrapped up in half the
time it's taken Hank to get to whatever
point he's at now they would have
already been three molds deep at the
soda shop after sampling some of the
meth they shaved out the top of the stat
before Hank up dressed that morning no
more asking him to drive you on
stakeouts it's too dangerous
you hear me and not to mention illegal
is it just me or are these two
completely different video game
controllers one looks like a pretty
standard Xbox 360 controller but the
other looks like maybe a Dreamcast
controller even if it's some kind of
weird third-party controller why
wouldn't the props Department find two
at the same time less
lassiter URL you said I helped you in
the berries and a barrel the Mexican
decimals there are worse ways to be
buried so one could argue this advice /
wish she is indeed helpful let's be a
little more glass-half-full their
pigment their leaves and other debris
scattered all over this yard there's
almost zero chance
Tyra's would be able to sneak up on Walt
I get the Gus's the small but ain't no
one wearing a coat like this in the
midday New Mexico Sun you can't kill me
because Jesse wouldn't cook for you if
you did well what does stopping us from
threatening to kill Jesse's loved ones
of paper fuses him this is this person
that you said could could disappear me
give me a whole new life Robert Forester
shadowing this episode's pact the
shadowing time practically in the DEA
family I go to their Christmas parties
for Christ's sake they know me they know
my voice on a random phone call I know
that wall has reasons for keeping us
clear this is possible but the writers
gotta come up with a better reason than
this for getting Saul involved use a
goddamn voice modulator doesn't scream
exist in this universe you just give me
an hour to I need to collect my wife and
kids okay
just give me an hour and then you make
the phone call Cranston is so good I've
been trying desperately all episode not
to give one back but damn it Brian
[Music]
always remember Cranston walks so the
Joker could run
[Music]
IRS code allows us to deduct from your
taxable income a percentage of your work
space relative to your overall home so
when we gotta talk about your face
I'd like to take his his face oh look at
me Hector under captain no this is crazy
Skylar would never do this to me
rub went out like a man it's the
champagne of victory 50,000 volts of
electricity are now passing into your
skeletal muscle tissue your central
nervous system has been incapacitated
but you will regain motor functions
momentarily are you listening to me
what's in the box what do you say
[Music]
where's the rest